a lot of people in our audience use  Craigslist so I like to help out I  thought would help our audience members  make a sale or connection by showing  some of their craigslist ads right here  on the show as a service to you now  let's check out the first ad service  offered I will teach you to lie about  knowing how to play the guitar in just  three minutes put it this way for hire  actor who excels at playing guy who  lives in shack by the beach available  for parties Toledo Ohio 7 morning DJ  team PJ and the stink man for hire and  she knows most affordable Bob Saget  impersonator  [Applause]  he's affordable yeah yeah very much so  it's a lot of people going for that gig  and finally looking to swing to  laid-back hippies seeking a third  [Applause]  you